um we're going to be getting further
than just a few seconds so otherwise we
might end up finding yourself needed by
us it allows for everybody who's
participating to just be able to listen
without an eruption there will be an
opportunity during our Q&A portion for
you to unmute and ask questions if you'd
like but for the majority for the
duration of the actual presentation and
for our session we'd us that you meet
ourselves let's see we're gonna wait and
let people join as they come trickling
in and we'll go ahead and get started in
just a few seconds waiting for some
last-minute folks to come and join us
okay so maybe while we're waiting if
people want to let us know where they're
joining from today so we can kind of
start to see where everybody's at and
where they're coming from and that'd be
great you can do so in the chat option
and just let us know where you're come
where you're participating from I'm in
facing difference ago today so I'm
joining from Udacity San Francisco
office
um I'm wondering where we have folks
coming from for Santa Cruz Alabama
that's exciting
Florida okay welcome let's see okay
we'll keep that getting added in and I
think we can looks like everybody has
everybody you have some last few more
joiners participating I'm gonna make
just one more reminder um if you haven't
done so already please go ahead and mute
yourself just so that way everybody can
listen in without interruption and we
don't have any unneeded background noise
I'm it is very disrupting for other
participants as well as the recording
that we're making so please go ahead and
meet yourself if you haven't already see
people adding to the chat Wow somebody
all the way from Kenya welcome Austin
Texas Pennsylvania welcome I'm glad that
you guys are all here with us today okay
so let's go ahead and get started and as
people keep continue to join they can
continue to introduce themselves and
just remember please new to yourself
okay so um
today our conversation is on a day in
the life of a cloud engineer and we are
joined by two of our Udacity alumni so
they're going to be able we're going to
be asking them some questions to learn
more about their experience and what
they're working on today we are gonna
have a live Q&A session at the end or
you can either ask questions directly in
the chat and well-well I will ask them
on your behalf or you can unmute
yourself and ask as well so if you have
any questions go ahead and reserve them
for the end so we can all at the same
time
go ahead some forever just durian go
ahead and please mute yourself that'd be
much appreciated okay
so let's I am so my name is Rachel I am
a member of the Udacity careers team I'm
a program manager on our content and
services side who essentially that means
I am in charge of building out and
maintaining and the career content you
guys are you guys have access to is part
of any nano degree that you enroll it as
well as the additional service programs
that you have that you have access to
should you enroll so that includes from
career coaching that includes career
projects like a resume review etc so
just know that if you participated in
any of those that is my doing me and my
team we built that out and provide that
for you guys and I have been and I've
worked at Udacity for about the last
four years and I've gotten to see a lot
of the exciting changes we've done and
how careers has kind of taken off within
those and I'm excited to have two
graduates of different nano degree
programs today who are sharing their
experience with their job search posting
so without further ado today's agenda is
we're going to meet our guests ot Anzhi
and Robert and then we're gonna go into
a brief introduction into like what is
cloud computing and so that way you guys
have some context to set up the rest of
the chat today then from there we're
going to move into a question and answer
portion where I have some questions I'm
going to be asking both tansy and Robert
about their experience with Udacity and
actually asked her as well so what are
they doing today and then we're gonna
talk a little bit about the future of
cloud computing in careers and where do
they see it going and then we're gonna
take some questions so that's going to
be when you guys can ask your questions
so maybe save them to the very end and
ask them then okay so our first alumni
guest is Robert Crowe on Robert was kind
enough to share a little bit of his bio
with us which is here presented on the
slide but Robert I love for you to take
the opportunity now to kind of introduce
yourself and share with our participants
today a little bit about you well hi I'm
Robert Crowe I'm a developer advocate at
Google in the tensorflow team and
developer advocate is kind of a liaison
between a product development team and
the developers who are using the
software or hardware that the team is
developing so my background is I have
been in software for a long time I was
managing a consulting group for for 12
years doing primarily web development
web application development really so
things like you know CMS or custom
systems that kind of thing and I just
kind of gradually drifted into more of a
data science focus I had some earlier
work that I did in data science and I
kind of went back to that and eventually
did
two different mana degrees and I'm
actually currently working in a third so
I did the machine learning the degree
and the artificial intelligence
intelligence 10 degree so those led to
me making a career change or I guess it
was sort of part of the process of doing
a career change I moved into a role as a
data scientist start up here and put the
teen out worked there for about a year
and then Google called and described
this role and at first I was like well
developer advocate I mean I really like
tensorflow but I'm not sure that's
really what I want to do that I wouldn't
talk to people and you know listen to
what is actually involved in the role
with the with the daily you know the day
to day life is and so forth and that
actually sounded like a lot of fun so I
really couldn't turn it down so that's
how I got where I am I'm happy to go
into depth in any of that maybe I'm you
could share with us the current you see
you mentioned that you're currently
working at a degree which one is it
AI in training okay so I you know it's
it's a branch of AI there's a lot of
finance involved in it so it seemed like
it'd be interesting it is it is
interesting so we'll get into a little I
think we'll be able to get a little bit
more into detail on like what you've
studied and how you see it relating to
your current job as well as the future
and but first I would like to take some
time to introduce Jonesy
but first before I do that can anybody
who could just join with who just joined
who isn't muted please mute yourself
it's really hard there's a lot of
background noise and it's definitely
hard for us to focus so I'm assuming
it's hard for guests to focus and also I
want to make sure that the audio
recording for this recording is as good
as possible for any people who watch
after okay so Jonsey go ahead and share
with
a little bit about you what brought you
to audacity and any any additional
information on your background yes sure
I was working as a data scientist in the
media industry when I heard about the
self-driving car nanodegree and I was
one of the first to sign up and had a
lot of fun all the challenges doing that
one in nanodegree and very fortunately
after that I was able to get interviews
with Google Amazon and some car
companies and I chose Google in the end
and I am working as a developer programs
engineer in Google for for the Google
cloud team specifically in a space of
data analytics and ml right now and I'm
still learning the ropes still learning
how to do my job well I'm very new to
cloud and I'm happy to share whatever
that that can be useful for people
coming into this space great thank you
um so for those of you who were gonna
switch really quickly and just some like
context for our cloud computing and so
for those of you who are joining without
a lot of understanding our background
into what it is here's a little just a
high-level overview so today's all
companies seem to be adopting a new way
of hosting information on the cloud as
things I think we've all heard about it
but what is it right and what does it do
and who works on it and it's project the
the industry itself is projected to grow
obviously about 17.3% and into a over
two billion dollar industry and
throughout the rest of 2019 which means
there's a lot of opportunity for folks
who are trying to get into it and
there's a lot of and I think that both
rubbered and chauncey can speak to that
a little bit in terms of what they see
on their on their day to day
kind of functions and and what they're
doing within their jobs at the moment so
there's quite a number of services that
allow folks to work within the cloud so
Google is one of them so is AWS which i
think is one of the ones that people
think about automatically when the King
comes a cloud and sorry so what we are
the the nano degree programs in the
school of cloud computing that we the
audacity has launched and we'll be
having our first nano degree classes
open next week and are helping students
to kind of navigate this and get an
introduction into cloud computing and
what it means to work in that space and
eventually go into the a developer so
with that I wanted to start talking to
both tansy and Robert with about a
little bit more about their background
and starting with your experience as a
Udacity student like what brought you to
dasa T and kind of the transition that
you took after that so you guys both
were working in the industry in
different spaces before and I wanted to
he know a little bit more from both of
you about what what was it specifically
about Udacity that Julie to a narrow
degree and why did you choose to enroll
and just type of a program versus others
I I can start first
I remember in November 2015 I'm ever
there was announced to me from Google
that it's making its machine learning
framework public and that's tensorflow
and I looked around for like classes I
could take to learn more about
tensorflow and remember your density has
one and I don't remember seeing things
on Coursera and edex which is which are
the other two that I was using the other
time and I and I took that and I would
it was the videos were really short
because it's like the content was quite
um quite intense
I remember spending like three four
months working through that small course
and it just gave me the impression that
she does is very quick to turn something
that's cutting edge into something that
people like me like a working
professional could take and when the
self-driving car nanodegree came out
like hose the same thing like nobody
else is teaching self-driving car
technology and I and I have always
wanted to work in some futuristic
technology and that just caught my
attention and I really really wanted to
win bro and I applied great what about
you Robert what was your experience so I
didn't start with Udacity in terms of
online resources I I started with I
think it was EDX I I took a class a two
series class in in spark and spark ml
and that kind of I that was because I
had previous experience with Hadoop and
I knew that spark was coming along so so
that led to the interning Coursera
course which is sort of canonical in the
industry if you're gonna do any kind of
ML and it's a it's a good foundation but
it's just one course it's not a degree
so I was looking for for more depth
after that I mean I felt like I had the
beginnings but I wanted more depth so I
was looking around at some of the other
offerings that are around and there's a
lot of them but Udacity just seemed you
know from what I could tell looking at
the syllabus is over where that seemed
to be the highest quality so that's what
I was interested in and I started with
the annual degree and since then I kind
of just stuck with Udacity I don't know
I should probably look again with my
heaven
well that was gonna be my follow-up
question is what is the fact that you've
taken now up you're on your third nano
degree with us a signal that you find
value in the program or is it that you
are just interested by the programs that
we have that we offer
and you've just decided to continue to
enroll well I'm kind of driven by my
interests that's like I'm not looking to
get a job in finance or anything for
this current nano degree it's more just
something I'm interested in but yeah so
and in fact when I took the other two
nano degrees I wasn't really sure it was
gonna work as a data scientist or where
I was going to work I was more
interested in sort of building a general
skillset in an area that I was
interested in and then you know just
kind of look around at careers after
that I mean I was aware of there's a lot
of different roles out there and a lot
of different types of companies so it
wasn't like I was unaware of the job
market but I hadn't really picked a
particular direction yet and I think you
guys are both actually like living
examples of the fact that continued
education and just perfectly skill
development whether it is to upskill
yourself and get a new job or for just
personal fulfilment can open new doors
and new opportunities which is why
lifelong education is such a critical
part of obviously what we're doing what
we're trying to do at Udacity and I
think just a such a vital part for
personal growth yeah absolutely I mean I
would totally amplify that the you know
the other thing that I've seen happen is
this rise of online education which you
could view in different ways
I think traditional institutions
probably are starting to view it more
positively but it's it's sort of a
competitor for them as well but you know
the luxury that that provides of being
able to follow your interests with the
schedule that you have and have a very
focused very very condensed curriculum
but is very high quality that's that's
something that just didn't exist you
know what ten years ago yeah so that's
been great and I think you guys are both
also we'll get into this more I think a
look and as we continue on through our
conversation but Hugh is also a
representative of
fact that there are so within a nano
degree and within the skills you learn
in a program it actually allows you a
lot of opportunities to branch to take
that information and to take that skill
and kind of parlay it into a number of
opportunities in terms of the job search
if that's the direction you're choosing
to go in you know so going from data
science into machine learning and now
into cloud computing like that that's a
trajectory that maybe you guys neither
one of you would have thought that you
would have taken after completing the
standard of your even when you enrolled
in it but it's definitely I think a
representative of the fact that with new
skills doors open and new opportunities
present themselves and being open is
kind of a critical part of that so my
next question for you both is
specifically like what was the most
impactful part of your Udacity
experience or part of your nano degree
was it like a specific project that you
took or something you engaged in or
participated in after graduating even
you know was there that kind of moment
for you and if so what was it for me I
think the biggest impact is I was able
to build confidence I'm going like build
confidence and doing in doing make
software engineering plus M at all
things that's not data science the the
content of the self-driving car nano JP
was challenging I remember there's like
three terms the first term is using
computer vision using a mouth for
computer vision for self-driving cars
and that's the story behind that's so
like in my domain and not in my domain
like like something that I I can I can
do I just need to challenge myself a
little bit and then
the second term and the third term go
into things like C++ and localization
common filters and system integration
all of those are things I have never
ever studied and just working working it
through and knowing that there are
people with me who are also new to this
and they're working working through this
just all of that I was like a great
positive energy and I was able to like
after everything's done I'm I feel I
feel such a tremendous sense of like a
chief chief and it really built my
confidence good so it helps you kind of
bridge the gap of confidence because
that's a I think that's a something we
all struggle with regardless of the
career path we are trying to get into
and even our background and I have an
every graduate I've ever worked with on
their job search talks about having a
lack of confidence so I think that's a
key one something else that you
mentioned was the commute like you
started to kind of refer to the
community piece and having knowing that
there are other people working on one
side you that are also doing the same
things and possibly struggling kind of
kept you motivated and I think community
and I'm a peer engagement is definitely
something we are trying to emphasize and
and make part of our future nanodegree
offering so that's that's key glad you
mentioned that um so we you both touched
on this a little bit in terms of what
your post to post nano degree experience
is like but when you completed it did
you initially intended like did you go
into this intending to search for a job
or you know what was it after for a new
Robert for example was it was it until
was it when you got contacted by Google
for example about a new opportunity that
really kind of struck you in terms of oh
yeah I can't make a career switcher was
it something you were toying around with
even before initial contact so it was it
was before that as well well before that
I
I had a client where I was doing an m/l
project doing predicting movement of
people through airports so that was that
was through my consulting firm and then
from there I went to a start-up working
as a data scientist in the networking
field so worked there for a little over
a year and it was only after that that
that Google contacted me so so I was I
was well you know well past the the
nanodegree graduation stage by that time
but I'll tell you I'll tell you what
struck me when I was at the startup we
were interviewing like crazy trying to
find more more data scientists because
we needed you know like three more at
least and and we were interviewing you
know people with with masters and PhDs
and I I would have some interview
questions you know about ml and they
just they didn't like mine out of 10 at
least did not know the answers and and
that's what it kind of struck me that
you know this is nano degree thing well
I guess it was pretty good after all
Wow glad to hear that when you were
interviewing other people
it hits you but you actually learned a
lot in your program do you feel like um
do you think that that was isolated to
just that type of role or do you think
that like for example your experience
going through the day to annelid eight
of science side please make sure that
you guys are muted to I hear somebody
talking okay I think I was able to meet
them and I lost my train of thought so
do you feel as though would you expect
that type of same positive like outcomes
for folks who I mean maybe maybe this
isn't answerable right because if you
haven't taken any other nano degree you
don't know exactly what the content is
or what's covered in it but do you feel
like it was
like that kind of realization that you
had was specific to your experience in a
nano degree do you think that and
therefore maybe other people who
complete other nanodegrees could have
like a leg up in interviewing down the
road simply because of what they learn
and and the fact that it kind of is is
like there's grit behind it and their
self driven do you feel like that's a an
assertion that maybe you can make or
maybe I'm trying to like jump and ask a
question that's just not even possible
right now yeah kind of so I mean I think
there's a certain type of person who can
do an an agree in the first place
is just you have to be you know pretty
self organized and self driven because
there's not you know someone forcing you
to go to class or read it every week or
something but in general I mean I think
yeah I can only really speak for the
nerd degrees I did but I mean I think
the quality of education is pretty high
i what surprised me was it that it was
that I we were not getting people from
traditional institutes institutions did
not seem to have the same level of
education so that's not all I mean we
definitely had some that were really
sharp but that was the surprise for me
they they had more of a general
background in things like statistics and
more traditional data analytics and and
not so much in ml and software
development okay make sense so then what
did you guys do to prepare when you guys
were interviewing um so when you got
that call from Google or channeling when
you were preparing to go to that
in-person event what were some of the
preparation tools that you guys used or
practice methodology is that you put
into practice for yourself personally me
the very first interview happened upon
physical hiring I think that organized
the biodiversity in California I was in
New York at the time I was so um I
I really really want to transition from
media to tech I I was willing to pay the
rent from my pocket money and I think I
came to Cal for a just just so I can
meet some of the companies that are
hiring and to prepare for that um
Udacity actually we offered what would I
call them they are like interview
coaching from some from I think other
you does do students but who are more
who have been like Todd how did hugging
coaches so I signed up for a call with a
data scientist he was based in Canada
and he was so helpful um he coached me
for half an hour of what to say and he
also looked at my resume he after the
colony sends me an email with just so so
many resources to look look at like what
are the 10 questions to propel now job
for a data center op and I've benefited
from that wasn't technical it's just if
you get 15 minutes you sit down with
someone from that company and they will
go over your resume and learn about what
you do um so that very first one was
just prepared from the resources that
you dusty was able to gives me okay so
talking to somebody else to kind of
practice helped you okay Robert what
about you
was there anything specific that you did
or practice yeah so the whole there were
there was a whole like term almost after
you finished a nano degree where it's
all about career development and and
resume development so forth and I I
hadn't I've been running a consulting
firm for several years so I hadn't
interviewed for you know except to
interview with clients I I hadn't done
that kind of thing for a long time so
so the help with a resume and you know
just interviewing was good there were
some other resources that I also
use there's a there's a book called
cracking the coding interview which is
very useful there's also a service
called called cramp or pee ramp we're
useful for working on coding interviews
because you do this phone screen thing
where you're coding online usually in a
document instead of an IDE so that takes
some getting used to and then that was
good practice and also I mean Google was
not the first place I interviewed with a
lot of other of other places later
people Facebook and Amazon okay actually
that was the second interview with
Google so what advice would you guys
have for a student or a graduate or
anybody that's about to go into an
interview because they're like one piece
of advice you give them suggestions
we're talking about interviews right now
yeah you know there's a tendency to
worry about the interview and worry
about freezing up and I definitely felt
that but when I actually after doing a
few interviews it got easier so the
first ones were harder so my advice is
just you know interview as much as you
can just and maybe schedule a few
interviews at the beginning that for
places where you be or maybe you're not
as interested in working just just for
the practice some of the advice that
needs to give graduates who we were
working with one-on-one so yep I fully
support that what about you TMZ is there
anything else you'd like to add pretty
much the same accent I don't love just
keep trying yeah yeah I like to say
practice like have interviews as
practice interviews um nothing really
creates the environment of an actual
interview an interview right there's
never the same nerves there's never the
same like moment of suspense and kind of
uncertainty so yeah okay so now I'd like
to I would like to kind of switch into
digging into digging in deeper into what
your current roles are and what you're
doing on a daily basis
so T on Z I'd like to start with you you
had mentioned when we were preparing for
this that your role is kind of like a
deep you the way you described it was
like 80% of your job is working in
programming and then 80 percent of that
80 percent is working in the cloud and
the other 20% is working in ml and like
the AI space so I would love to kind of
hear a little bit more from you about
what that actually looks like and what
are you working on as a developer
programs engineer and maybe kind of
explain that a little bit more and kind
of walking through walking us through
like a day your your day okay um so
you're right that about 80 percent of my
time is spent on more engineering tablet
work and then alternate person education
related type of work and out of that 80
percent engineering 80 percent I spent
on a Google product it's called cloud
pub/sub
and the other 20% I spend on cloud ml
all kinds of Amami api's so what do I do
in my day I every day is different but
these are the three buckets of things
that I see myself doing the first bucket
is I figure out what developers are
struggling with what they're complaining
about what kind of things they would
like us to have in the space of pub/sub
an amount and I
I basically gather feedback input I talk
to the engineers I talk to product
manager I talk to the tech writer and I
figure out where the friction is when
people use pops up for instance and um
and the second the second thing is I I
will I will done figure out okay
okay first I under understand their
problems and then I figure out how to
solve the problem or if it's not a
problem if it's a new feature that's
coming out for cloud pub/sub then
totally in the second bucket is I need
to understand how the feature works
before it gets released to the public or
I need to figure out what's the best way
to help that developer with a particular
problem and and the third bucket is once
I figure something out
I share that knowledge through could be
a tutorial could be some sample codes
that would put on github could be could
be me just tweeting that something has
been fixed or reaching out to the
developer or to the larger community
that this is available for them to use
now circle every day is different but
this is like the it's the overarching
story overarching themes of nearing day
to day work okay what about your job do
you enjoy the most
I am constantly not learning new things
and I like working going from something
that I like whatever I'll appeal
appealed to me most is that they're
looking for people who really loves
learning and they're looking for people
who are empathetic towards towards
developers pain so yeah love of learning
learning yeah it's not like you also do
a lot of work to make things simpler for
others so it's it's learning but it's
also trying to provide solutions that
improve the lives of other developers
and I think there's a lot of a lot that
can be taken out of that so that's great
thank you so Robert what about you can
you give us a little bit more insight
into what a developer advocate does and
what your day-to-day life looks
sure so I work with the tensorflow team
and my team the devrel team we have
seven das or developer advocates and two
DPS or developer program engineers and
two tech writers and we're like the team
is tasked for the whole tensorflow
universe so there's a there's like core
tensorflow
and then there's all these other parts
of tensorflow there's extensive the
light digital Jas tensor from serving
there's there's tensorflow
ranking there's all these different
parts of tensorflow so we divide those
up and and we each have a different
focus
my focus is what's called tensor flow
extended or T FX and T FX is the the
tensor flow platform that you use to
when you have a train model you want to
put it into production so you make it
available to the world that that could
mean putting it on a server or it could
mean deploying it as a mobile
application or as a JavaScript
application so that's that's my focus
and then within that as a developer
advocate my job is to try to make really
communicate out to developers who are
using it how both how to use it and what
the story is so there's a lot of parts
to that I just yesterday shot a series
of five YouTube videos that that will be
coming up here so I do things like that
I'm writing blog posts there's there's a
lot of that and those are you know
they're they're technical blog posts but
there also is a writing thing I do a lot
of development of examples and collabs
and I developed a workshop and taught
the workshop and I'm going to Europe and
Asia here next week to deliver
that that workshop and so it's a lot of
different things all around sort of this
central focus of this one software
platform Wow and along with that of
course nothing stand still so as Tamsin
said I'm I'm learning everyday there's
there's new stuff every day which you
know it can be it can be challenging it
moves fast but it's also a lot of fun so
I really like that yeah I think people
have a wrong conception or a
misconception that and when you get a
job it's almost like learning is done
like their life is segmented into
education and then work and oftentimes
that's not the case look if you are done
learning
you're probably like you probably may
want or you if you're done like feeling
inspired to learn or excited to learn
then you might need to find a new job or
a new career path or company if you're
no longer inspired to do that so yeah so
one question I had for you Robert was
something that we touched on on while we
were holding our preparation session and
your you mentioned that your team at the
team you're currently on is no longer
specifically part of like the Google
cloud organization and instead you're
part of Google research so are there is
there anything that you're doing today
that is related to like the cloud
computing space or anything that there
there's are there any kind of like ties
over there yeah yeah so so tf-x by the
park and I'm focused on you need to
deploy it somewhere so there's really
two choices there you could deploy it on
a cloud or you could deploy it on
premises like in local data center and
what we're seeing in the industry in
reality is that there are a lot of
workloads that are still deployed into
data centers in fact the majority the
vast majority are still deployed into
data centers but increasingly they are
migrating to the cloud because reasons
for that in some cases is like legal or
regulatory requirements for the data
then there's probably
see concerns as well you need to to
manage as as well as where you keep you
know as far as what where you keep what
data so for me the cloud piece of that
is understanding the cloud offering that
goes along with tf-x
the tf-x as a service is wrapped into a
something called cube flow or a kinfolk
pipelines and towns ii might may be
familiar with that but that becomes an
option for people when i'm going on
talking to people but about tf-x if
they're interested in the cloud
deployment deployment then I'm pointing
them at Kid flow or keep fluid pipelines
as the way to do that and what that does
is it wraps tf-x
into a kubernetes environment and
there's a lot of scaling and management
that goes along with that so it becomes
a very powerful kind of solution but at
the same time you can have a hybrid
deployment where you're keeping some of
your pipeline on pram and controlling
that data and then scaling a you know
part of your pipeline on to the cloud
so understanding cloud deployments and
and cloud computing is a real important
part of of what i'm doing and frankly
what everybody's doing in the industry I
mean you you can't go anywhere where
there is a cloud happening I the the
started that I came from
we were running a hundred percent on the
cloud there was no physical data center
anywhere and that was a 24/7 real-time
application so it was a challenging
environment but they put together some
great technology to do that well I
appreciate the explanation thank you and
that definitely helps kind of clarify I
think it shows like how the cloud and
cloud computing is very is why it's
becoming such a big industry and why
there's now such a need for it and the
fact that there's now gonna pass there's
going to be a lot of job opportunities
in it for those who are interested so
thank you I appreciate that
you spent there so I wanted to kind of
talk to more of you to you guys both
less about your experience and more
about where do you see this going in the
future
so what I think I would like to first
start with is any advice that you would
give a fellow student or a graduate
about there how to make the most out of
their nano degree and therefore job
search any like just a piece of advice
or anything you'd like to pass on I
think do a great job on the project in
the nanodegree
and also learn should talk about the
projects to people of different
backgrounds somebody who have technical
backgrounds who maybe doesn't have that
technical background so for you working
with that the combination of the
projects you completed in the program
and then also the work you did with the
career counselor after made for a good
combination for you yes okay anything
that you'd like to include or something
different you'd like to share Robert
well so I mean I would you know echo
what tnz says I mean the other thing
that comes to mind is the nanodegree
gives you kind of the background and the
framework in a lot of different areas
but you need to try to read in the field
too they learn to read papers try to
keep up on blog posts and things because
you know the the Nano degrees are
developed as sort of a snapshot in time
but that field keeps moving forward so
you need to get in the habit of just
kind of staying on top of things yeah
so again we're never done learning okay
that's to happen there's always some
component of research and personal
development and all of that because I
think the one thing that will remain
constant within our job searches us
everything else around us is going to be
the agents of change
we sometimes need to match ourselves to
that versus expecting it to match us
that's been my piece of personal
feedback and like just over the last you
know 15 years of a job search personally
things I've noticed so um let's see here
the next set of questions are you know
where do you guys see what do you think
is in future or in in store for the
future of careers in cloud computing
based on like what you're doing today
and what you've been working on and just
the journeys you've taken like what do
you think is next well the future of
cloud computing to make to answer it's
kind of a lot yeah so there's been a
development of the initial sort of cloud
platforms and a lot of it was focused on
providing managed services and there's a
lot of advantages to managed services
but there needs to be if you're doing
hybrid deployments there needs to be
really close integration between an
on-prem and a cloud deployment it's if
you look what Google has done with the
anthos project they're really moving in
the direction of providing more of an
integrated kind of hybrid platform so
you don't cross a hard boundary and go
from a piece of software or software
platform into a managed service there's
more of a gradual transition chianti
probably knows more about that than I do
and mm-hmm I can't say and I know more
than you do okay
so maybe then we can move on to the next
question would be oh sorry go ahead
so justjust over
all you think learning what's out there
today and learning things like
kubernetes and me sews learning the the
platforms that are there the open-source
platforms especially things like spark
and flank are important but watch watch
for it as it evolves because it's it's
in one place now but you know here from
now it's going to be in a different
place and to the degree that you can
sort of be aware of that it helps in
where you focus good and which kind of
ties I think into my next question so
any predictions on where what do you
what you think the industry will be at
and in general like not just within
cloud computing but just kind of where
do we where do you see things being at
in the next like five 10 15 years any
advances you're predicting or you know
just just for fun um you know it's for
fun
anything you'd like to see or anything
you think will happen just you know try
to sync um definitely like I don't know
10 15 years but everything will be more
efficient like you're now it like
instead of waiting for amongst you you
know build it develop your app and start
a business get everything done maybe
it's just it's gonna be really really
fast to realize a very creative idea and
have the technology to back you up and
go to market really fast
I think the efficiency will be
incredibly improved because there's
cloud yeah and the world is gonna become
more connected yeah
[Music]
I guess I would say I expect to see you
know ml integration into applications
continue to grow so there's you know
currently today there's a lot of ml that
are in just you know a certain
percentage of the applications but as it
grows it's going to be sort of
everything
as I don't expect ml to to be more than
an augmentation of what the application
is currently doing but I do expect it to
be sort of more commonplace and what
that means for cloud is going to be
interesting because you have kind of two
different components of a ml at the edge
in mobile devices and things like
laptops and then you have the cloud
back-end for the integration of those
two I think will continue to grow and
it's hard for me to say how that split
is going to come out because they're
both getting faster but the the
applications and cells are getting more
demanding - fair enough thank you I know
that sometimes it's not it's not an easy
question to answer and because I think
in some ways the neck the next 10-15
years will probably show us things that
we didn't even think possible so it's
definitely not the easiest to predict
but thanks um okay let's see so you guys
kind of mentioned this specifically and
so this is the I think you know this is
a current snapshot of what if you just
did a quick like search in LinkedIn jobs
like what types of jobs are out there
that deal with cloud and I think we
based on today's conversation and the
type of work that both chamsy and Robert
are doing like you can start to see how
this is it's actually going to be
incorporated into a bunch of different
types of roles
it's gonna be more commonplace and less
stand-alone so it's gonna be part of I
think I would assume part of regular
development jobs instead of it being its
own entity but I think regardless of the
type of role cloud computing skills are
currently in demand and will only
increase in demand so it's a really good
opportunity at the time right now to
kind of jump in and get hit the ground
running even if it's not necessarily the
face that you saw yourself in when you
took your first nano degree or second
nano degree or even came to Udacity to
explore I think it can be utilized in a
lot of different ways and these the
example job titles that are listed here
are ones I pulled from the LinkedIn
search when I was just trying to
understand what the limits of today's
jobs in cloud is so for more information
um if there's anything any specific
questions you have on on jobs in this
space or the nanodegree I'd encourage
you to write in to support Udacity and
ask your question and it will make sure
that it gets addressed if you have a
specific question about the career
programs that we offer then right into
career - support at Udacity and that
will get funneled directly to the
careers team and we'll be able to answer
your questions specifically
so in the last 10 minutes or so of
today's session I wanted to open up the
room and let anybody who wants to ask
questions ask questions so at this time
you can and you yourself if you want to
ask a question live or you can ask it in
the chat and I can read it so if there's
any questions you'd like to ask you -
Chansey rather or both please do so now
and if there aren't any questions we can
go ahead and end the session early and
you guys are welcome to write in to
those same email addresses I mentioned
earlier and ask them and so any any
questions oh I think so we have one so
this T on Z it's for you so if the
hiring apart if the hiring event you
went to was at Udacity z-- June 2018
hiring partner Preview at Google
Sunnyvale I was
- it was a nice event so I guess not a
question just a comment they were there
- small world
and so from Mac it looks like okay so
Matt the questions you're asking are is
more about the projects that's currently
or part of the nanodegree program not
necessarily directed format or for
Robert Andy so for that question I would
encourage you to write in to support it
you'd ask me to get a full scope of
what's included in the syllabus and what
the projects are that come with the put
the program but the questions that I'm
that I want to ask right now are
specifically for either Robert or
chianti about their experience what
they're working on today or anything
you'd like to ask them so any any other
questions you want to eat want to ask
the question if not no problem it's a
little nerve-racking sometimes ask
questions in a group setting completely
understandable oh we have a question
okay so I see a question that came in on
chat and then also somebody raised their
hands so let's ask the question in chat
first and then I'll go to the person to
raise their hand thank you
so I Robert what's the difference
between our I guess it's for both of you
what's the difference between developer
advocate and the developer relations
role so developer advocate is part of
the developer relations team okay
so Debra L or developer relations is a
sort of an area within the organization
at Google and a lot of other tech
companies and developer advocate is just
one of one of the roles in that there's
really kind of three roles developer
advocate developer programs engineer and
developer well a tech writer the way it
was explained to me is that the two
roles of the developer advocate and
developer programs engineer are very
similar in what they do it's just the
split is a little different the dpe does
like a
coding and 20% other stuff and the DEA
like B does like 20% coding and the 80%
other stuff yeah great so I'm going to
go to the person now who raised their
hand and I'm going to unmute you so
you're welcome to go ahead and ask the
question now so the person who raised
their hand you want to go ahead and ask
your question okay so maybe not
let's go ahead there's a couple
questions that came in on the chat so
let's go switch back there okay so we
got a couple both questions seem to be
relating to how did the projects you
worked on any or nanodegree helped you
in your current job so did today and if
so how you guys are both thinking me in
the first end of degree I did there was
something called the capstone project
and for the capstone I use tensor flow
to do it was called an alux net model
and tensor flow was very new at that
time so that was a really good
experience and that actually led to a
project I did on contract after me so
that and of course now I work intensive
because it was a really useful thing for
me great
anything for you technically I could see
you thinking yes so I'm just very
generally um when I was collaborating
when I was working on the Udacity
project have to put them on github and
for that as a data scientist I didn't
really have to work with a lot but uh
you know like working on project is one
thing for working with collaborating
with other people on the on the final
project which was like victory
had to pull all codes together and put
it on our self-driving car and really
drive it and that required a
collaboration and really had to you know
learn the harder tricks of using it so
that's really helpful since I'm working
since the no part of my monetary now is
working on client libraries and I might
code it you know I contribute coding
data other than that the I am something
that I do fir kuqali 20% project or for
fun at work is you know the tutorials
that I write needs to be engaging and he
I'm something that I've wanted to I'm
still planning to do is showing how
people could build a common filter and
maybe too technical here but it's
something using predicting like
forecasting telemetry data and how how
something would go using pub/sub and
like basically turning what I learned in
this Africa in the submarine Camero
degree and putting it into what I know
about pub/sub and turn that into
creative interesting material that
people could read about yeah
so taking something that might not be so
engaging but making it engaging so
people kind of get it I'm definitely
gauging like common filters are great
stuff yeah thank you both though I think
that was helpful any so we have time for
maybe one more quick question if not any
other questions that come in let's go
ahead and you can ask us at the either
support at Udacity if there's a general
question or if it's a career specific
question ask it career - support we are
recording this session and we will be
sharing it with everybody who expressed
interest or RSVP'd for today's session
so keep an eye out for an email that
will include the recording link as well
as some additional resources
so with that being said let's go ahead
and just thank you both for joining
today and for participating and you know
sharing your experience and answering
our questions it's really appreciated
and um thank you everybody for joining
us and I hope to see you at future
events and please keep an eye out for
any now and we'll talk to everybody soon
okay have a good one thank you
you